this is one of my favorite days of the
year when we invite our student deacons
to share reflections and in the fall we
do it around all saints day and we ask
them with great latitude to reflect on
someone who's been like a saint to me
and we don't give them any further
instructions so we say that can be a
family member that can be a friend that
can be a teacher that could be a
preacher that could be a historical
figure that could even be a fictional
figure it could be anyone who's been a
spiritual influence in your life and
these are great great occasions every
year when we hear from the students in
our midst about their spiritual lives
and those who've been a blessing to them
and so we're going to do this with a
verse of a song in between each of the
reflections and so the assignment is
going to lead us in one verse of the him
you'll see it in your bulletin right
after the speakers the cancer will sing
the first verse then we'll have the
first reflection from Abby then the
Cantor will sing the second verse then
we'll have a reflection from Annabelle
and then you'll be invited to sing
verses 3 and 4 around those last two
reflections good morning if I pause all
of a sudden in the middle of my
reflection it's not because I've gone
John in a beatific vision of the living
creature is bowing down before the
throne of God but because I can't read
my handwriting and I don't really know
what possessed me to write my reflection
but um I'm going all analog these days
so I've been thinking about sayings ever
since Ian asked for reflections about
two weeks ago and as of yesterday i was
still without any thoughts and i was
unable to figure out wise since i'd
actually volunteered I'd rushed for this
chance to talk about things in my life
because I have the sense that my life is
overflowing with people who have blessed
me who've turned up at crucial moments
in my life and demonstrated that
Providence and grace or
real things but every time I considered
a person who had been important thinking
I yes this is someone that I can talk
about for a few pages this is someone
who has left his or her mark on my life
I'd find myself unable to commit to them
what was supposed to be an exercise in
gratitude had become an exercise in
frustration and that's why I'm not going
to talk about anyone today saying as I
was looking up the etymology that comes
from Latin Sanctus or sacred and sacred
comes from sare which comes from SAS air
or holy and holy to me is an interesting
word because it has connotations both of
being consecrated or set apart but also
connotations of that which is whole
intact uninjured in viola inviolable and
in transgressive all if that's a word
but I think you know what I mean I think
that we tend to think of the Saints in
our lives as those individuals who are
set apart whole the people who possess
these extraordinary integrity that
allows them to do extraordinary things
sayings with a capital S are those who
have had so much integrity that they've
been willing to die for their faith the
martyrs about whom hagiographies are
written st. Sebastian st. Agnes Santini
st. Peter etc and then there's those
Saints with a lowercase s whom we have
known in our lives who have shown as
beacons in their communities and been
exemplary figures I hear people talk
about their family members in this way
about a parent or a grandparent who
exemplifies unconditional goodness and
those things have no hagiographies
written for them and yet we know them by
our witness they have written themselves
into our lives our lives are there hey
geographies but this is not really what
I want to talk about today the st. I
want to reflect on are not the people
who have set themselves apart in my life
as being figures of integrity
Holness the fullest experience of
saintliness that i have the people who
most impressed me as being sinks are
those who make me feel upset apart who
make me feel that I have wholeness and
integrity and perhaps this is a selfish
or a self-centered way of approaching or
conceiving of saintliness or st. said
but it is the way that it's most heavily
and deeply in my heart the Saints in my
life then are not necessarily those
people who would be considered saintly
in the conventional sense of the term
they are not necessarily people that I
know or people that I will ever see
again I have enemies or people whom i
find difficult to like or love or even
people whom I love to hate and these
people usually take away from my sense
of integrity and wholeness and yet there
are moments in passing when they will
say something or do something and I
can't help but be impressed and think ah
and then usually that moment passes very
quickly and I returned to my attitude of
snarkiness and hating and and you no
rush to call a friend to dish about this
horrible person and yet in the moments
preceding that he's proceeding there my
sort of return to unloving pneus they
have been seems to me they have reminded
me even in there unlike ability in their
unloved ability of my wholeness and of
my set of partners that are my
birthright as a human being as someone
who has been made in the image of God as
tarnished as an image my team in those
moments handwriting mmm
skip couple lines mmm so head to the
stranger who laughed during a movie I
don't know if you've seen Martha Marcy
Marlene may know Marcy May Martha Martha
Marcy May Marlene the latest elizabeth
Olsen movie releases disturbing not a
movie really laugh at and yet I laughed
in the middle of it however mine was not
the only voice laughing there was
another woman laughing with me and in
that moment to be the only person
laughing at what was obviously an
appropriate thing she was a saint to me
to the redhead man who refused to give
me his address that I could reimburse
him for his giving me two hundred
dollars so that I wouldn't have to spend
the night in on the airport floor
because I taken the bus the wrong day to
the airport you are a saint to my mother
who sends me food packages with
chestnuts that she has roasted and
meticulously peeled herself and I feel
like the Koreans here I can identify
with the side of their mothers making
food for them and then she's telling me
about the nutritional benefits and food
and telling me that bananas are the best
for stress relief and am i eating
bananas and don't eat too many chestnuts
because they'll make me fat and she
tells me that the health looks that she
sent with the package costs forty
dollars she is a saint to the man who
smelled of soap when I was walking
behind them on Whitney Avenue that smell
of clean mingling with the smell of
autumn you are saying to all of those
who bake the communion bread to all
those who partake of it to all those who
are present with it even as they do not
partake of it you have been Saints to me
because in that moment I am reminded of
the wholeness that can be mine All
Saints is the day when we are called to
remember those people who are Saints but
I think it is also the time to remember
that we are all saints as corny as that
can sound that we have all and I'm
certain of this reminded someone of
their
wholeness I think it's a lot easier to
think of the saintliness of others than
to think of our own saintliness it's
easier more comfortable to be a sinner
who me a sink got to be kidding i do XY
and z I think a B and C about so-and-so
that person this person etc and yet i
think it is with saintliness as with
much else that it takes one to know one
life someone's life holiness summons
holiness one cannot set apart unless one
is oneself set apart the image of God
cannot be recognized safe through the
eyes of God all saints yes amen good
morning everyone i go through phases
where i would read up on the life of a
historical synced so i go through phases
of st. so i went through my saint
francis face i went through my st. Clair
face i'm going through my bartolomé de
las casas face right now sorry I'm if I
put your Spanish sorry Ian and James so
we go to school and we take history
classes and we remember the big figures
in history remember George Washington or
Abe Lincoln or Martin Luther King and
then there the minor people in history
class that are easily forgotten but I
just can't remember I can't forget the
time I learned about bartolomé de las
casas it was a Friday afternoon I was
sitting in section and the class was
about human rights and my professor
professor charles hill he asked an
interesting question he said how many of
you believe you have a soul and that's
sort of unusual
we looked puzzled at each other yes for
not soulless evil people but we didn't
say anything and then professor Hill
began to tell the story of bartolomé de
las Casas las Casas was a Spanish
missionary and historian who was one of
the first human rights advocates he
sought for better treatment of the
native population in Latin America he
was born in 1484 in Seville and as a
young man he traveled to the Indies and
for most of his life he was far from
perfect like his neighbors he used
native slave labor and then when he
turned 40 he had a profound revelation
he came to a moral awakening he saw all
the brutality that was happening around
him it was a permanent change he decided
to free his slaves and devote the rest
of his life to lobbying on behalf of the
Native Americans a lot of his efforts
failed he attempted to found a peaceful
sediment on the coast of Venezuela where
Spaniards and natives could work
side-by-side complete disaster he
successfully pushed for laws to ban
native slavery but those laws were not
enforced at all his most important work
he documented the injustice is done to
these natives but those when ignored in
his native Spain yet one of his idea
stuck around and that really resonated
with me so in 1550 there was a great
debate at the city of Valladolid in
Spain and the big question on the table
was how should the native population of
Latin America be treated it was a big
profound theological question most of
the people argued that they were not
equal with Europeans so these Native
Americans can be subjugated but las
Casas had a different view he believed
that all human beings have souls
because we are all made in the image of
God therefore we should treat everyone
with respect and dignity and this is a
quote from him does this does not dis-
precepts apply to all men in general see
that you do not do to another what you
would not have done to you by another
and the same for the affirmative command
so always treat others as you would like
them to treat you this is something that
every man knows grasps and understands
by the natural light that has been
imparted to our minds so we have come a
long way since the days of Spanish
colonialization we have laws regarding
human rights but the problems still
exist we have big scale problems human
trafficking political violence
oppressive regimes now it's time to kind
of step back and look at our own
community this debate about how we
should treat other people still applies
video community on November first the
new the Yale Daily News opinion page
published a guest column the guest
columnist was advocating for more
objectification we seem bizarre at first
but then you he he writes
objectification is a necessary part of
life how many people can we actually
care about sounds really cynical the
shots that sent shockwaves through our
readers people wrote to us saying how
can you publish something like this and
again when you look at ourselves
sometimes it's easy for us to view other
people as means and not ends as
Christians we often cite the Golden Rule
but often we find ourselves guilty of
not treating those around us with full
dignity and respect we forget to
remember our neighbors as equal children
of god what an awesome and challenging
responsibility it is to be a children of
God and we reflect upon this as we sing
today later on
the saints of God are just folk like me
and I mean to be 12